[Music]
I'm 200 ft up a cliff and it's a Tuesday
I'm a day trader and here's the day in
my life just a few years ago I didn't
actually have the lifestyle that I
wanted and now I can take an afternoon
off on a workday let me show you what
has made this possible and how you can
apply it to your own life
[Music]
check this out so I'm actually in a
trade right now it's up about
$1,900 I bought in down here and the
Market's kind of gone up in my favor
really well and this red line right here
is where I've Trail my stop up and I'll
probably get knocked out you can see
there it knocked me out and so locked in
my profits for the day so with that
trade I'm actually going to be done for
the day it's about 8:40 right now and I
generally only trade for 2 to 2 and a
half hours a day and this is because if
you're doing trading right it's actually
really really boring and I don't allow
myself to you know go on my phone or
watch YouTube while I'm trading because
I've actually missed trades or lost
trades because I was distracting myself
and so I found that I have to try and
sit there and you know I'll stretch or
you know twiddle my thumbs or play tug
war with my dog but I do something
that's not super engaging because in
this day and age with technology being
what it is it's so so easy to lose the
skill of patience and in reality when it
comes to trading I would say patience is
the number one key when it comes to
trading so if you're actually a Trader
you have to almost practice the skill of
being bored and being patient and that's
something that's really hard to do and
and I struggle with every day still
after trading I take a break by going
for either a walk a trail run or the dog
park I do this because trading is
surprisingly stressful even if you're
just sitting there you're Conant having
to analyze and make decisions which is
really draining and this break allows me
to reset and focus for the rest of the
[Music]
day wait wait C cut c c anyway after the
walk and some food I sit down to work
for a couple hours I like to organize my
days in blocks work for 2 hours then
take a break I found it makes me way
more productive because it prevents
burnout now I live for a challenge
everything I do challenge is me trading
building a YouTube channel and my
outdoor activities are a challenge it
all pushes me to be stronger mentally
and physically now after another 2hour
segment of work I normally head to the
gym for a workout but today isn't a
normal day
[Music]
so a lot of the outdoor activities I do
can really depend on the season or just
what we're kind of feeling at the time
and it's either rock climbing up you
know crazy kind of cliffs going up
glaciated mountains where you have to
jump over massive cracks in the ice or
just skem down a mountain that we just
hiked up and so these are usually
reserved for the weekend though because
they can take a long time sometimes
we're going for 17 hours straight on
some of these trips and so in the work
week you know clearly you don't have
that much time so today we're going on
to a more of a local spot it'll be
shorter quicker as our outing and I've
also got something happening later today
at 8:00 that I need to make sure I'm
back
[Music]
for and now for the most important part
of any day in the life video an
expensive car reveal
[Music]
yeah just kidding it's just a dirty
super
[Music]
Outback we just made it to the base of
the climb we're going to start here and
then just pretty much go all the way up
this kind of up here and zigzag back and
forth and I'm telling you it always
looks scarier than it actually is so
with rock climbing you usually go in
pairs of two one person has to go up
bringing a bunch of protection Gear with
them so they don't fter their death and
then the second person follows
collecting the gear as they go up so for
larger climbs like we're doing today
you're essentially leap frogging back
and forth climbing sections of the route
until you get to the top or if you're
crazy you can do what's called free
soloing and you climb without a rope or
any
protection you can actually see over
there across the way there's other
parties climbing up the other
Cliff once we got to the top we couldn't
just hike off because we were on this
massive Rock
pillar to get back down we have to do
what is called repelling it's where you
use gear to lower yourself down the Rope
safely because down climbing is
generally extremely hard or almost
impossible and then from there we just
hiked
out yes I have an alarm to go to bed
having the exact same nighttime routine
every day has changed my life this is
what I do I take my watch and phone and
put them in my office I found being on
my phone right before bed increases my
chance of struggling to go to sleep then
I start with a hot shower what this does
is it heats up my body doing two things
first it relaxes my muscles so if I have
anything that is tight or sore it's less
like it to make me uncomfortable while
sleeping second it causes my body to
start trying to cool down and research
has shown that what this does is it
starts your body producing melatonin
which is the hormone that helps make you
go to sleep the next big step is doing
some stretching after the hot shower
your muscles are loosened up and being
able to stretch will help them even more
I often have a tight lower back so
working that out before bed is important
so it doesn't bother me in the middle of
the night and interrupt my sleep
sometimes my brain will not shut off at
night and I'll sit in bed for hours
trying to go to sleep I found that
journaling before I go to bed as a brain
dump helps me get my thoughts out on
paper so I'm not thinking about it when
I'm trying to go to sleep also I write
my priorities and a rough schedule for
the next day this helps me go to the
next day with the purpose then finally I
get into bed and read I'll generally
read some science fiction story keeping
it simple I don't want to read something
that is super interesting and
stimulating my brain because that will
potentially wake me up I'll read until I
feel ready to fall asleep which is
generally 15 to 20 minutes and then from
there I'll generally fall asleep right
away